then Brian formed the house that I was
developing options to respond to
Russia's continued aggression in a
calibrated and determined manner today I
can confirm that the UK is donating
Storm Shadow missiles to Ukraine
Storm Shadow is a long-range
conventional only Precision strike
capability it complements the long-range
systems already gifted including high
miles and Harpoon missiles as well as
Ukraine's own net to increase missile
and longer range missions elsewhere
gifted the donation of these weapon
systems gives Ukraine the best chance to
defend themselves against Russia's
continued brutality especially the
deliberate targeting of Ukrainian
civilian infrastructure which is against
international law Ukraine has a right to
be able to defend itself against this
the use of Storm Shadow will allow
Ukraine to push back Russian forces
based within Ukrainian Sovereign
territory